ding-ding-ding-ding and welcome back to
civilian podcast and one five-speed
you're not listening this 1.5 speed but
I bet you thought you were right by the
farmers dog it's time to start feeding
your dog better food not higher
processed crap that they're probably
eating now nothing against you you've
already insulted our listeners and
tricked them
the farmers dog is giving you a great
offer you get 50% off your two week
trial of fresh healthy food for your dog
by going to the farmer's dog calm slash
annejulien or click the link in the
description plus you get free shipping
also guys if you're looking to build a
website you're really pleased with
yourself where space is the way to do it
god
so whatever website you have in mind for
your business or your hobby online store
domain make it with Squarespace a dream
is just a great idea treem is just a
great idea that doesn't have a website
yet make it a reality in this
Squarespace right now head to
Squarespace comm / Jenna Julian for a
free trial and then also to save 10% of
your first purchase of a website or
domain with that URL quickly in the
description Jo what's Kermit doing
he was carpet swimming okay
why because I heard him like sneeze
cough into the carpet Marvel is not for
you he's going to sniff howdy partners
is the Halloweeny well not even really a
Halloween episode it's not Halloween yet
we should just do scary stuff all month
all right more like halfway through the
month already we're a little late on
this week's we're a little late on this
but we're gonna do some spooky stuff
what up it's your girl kelp careful with
that match Kelsey you're looking bright
and beautiful today Kelsey thank you are
you being careful with all of your
matches where'd you get that outfit
careful Ben oh just genuinely asking
where you got it but benefit sent it to
me a long time ago yeah
Benna Bay it's honestly benefit for some
reason just decided like they
occasionally like to send me some
scarers and stuff and i feel like such a
beauty guru your bureau car mate don't
kick no there's a bed right there for
you why do you have to go through this
every week look down lay down you can't
sit with careful with that match Kelsey
come in now go away
marbles laying on the carpet he forgot
where he is well what we thought we
would do for this episode was read scary
stories and these are true right I found
a website called darkness prevails where
one of the categories is true scary
stories and I let me tell you I was
looking through them last night and he
was dark out prevail dude I was I was
getting scared I am careful with that
match
you're laughing now she's making jokes
now but let the record show weird I'm
ready to be scared so there's a few of
them that I've read obviously just
because I want to make sure they're good
but then there's also a bunch that I
haven't so if there are some bad ones
don't worry it's Kelsey's fault not mine
it is not but so I got my Goyal we're
gonna cuddle up together so there's also
a story I wanted to share on unresolved
mysteries this one is very very highly
touted by the unsolved unresolved
mysteries subreddit and it was called
the mystery mysterious disappearance of
Brandon Lawson and I haven't read it yet
but it's looks good so we can get found
- if you want I keep thinking of some of
these at the end it's just gonna really
good giant troll no none of these are
trolls
none of them nothing I know you've read
them I've read them all right let's see
there's Gary are you sure and they're
real but there are real monsters these
are real these are real it's a great
tale
okay I'm gonna start I'm gonna start
pretty light okay we're gonna start
pretty late this one's called skinwalker
Byron okay
that was scary just it's over yes oh let
me read okay just sharing my quick story
I had zero idea what I had seen until
listening to some of your stories I
lived in a small Kermit literally dude
you're ruining everything go go in your
bed go on
nothing's as scary is Sarah Midland he
needs something
I can't they just leave cuz he wants to
sit in my lap but [ __ ] that we're
working she's a beautiful little boy God
put your tongue in your mouth and lay
down boy
he's like a luxurious furry dad on the
ground right here too
I lived in a small farming village about
300 of about 300 for a few years 300
people and lived in the village Larry
was rather close to the largest Edina
burial mounds in my state so I don't
know what it do you know what that is
Edina burial I don't know if it's
controversial to say Indian burial but
like Native American is that what that's
referring to yeah some of the most
haunted places I've been living in our
house for about a year now if I offended
you I'm not trying to and they recently
got a dog who was training to be my
service dog because I have multiple
sclerosis and I have severe balance
issues well about three months after
getting him it was around 2:00 a.m. in
the morning you don't need to say in the
morning and I was in the kitchen getting
a drink I heard my dog outside barking
it was not uncommon for this to happen
as I worked the night shift from home
and I would let him out to potty the
thing is I did not recall letting him
outside so I brushed it off as a ms
memory lapse and I went back to get him
but he wasn't at the base of our sorry I
went out to get him but he was at the
base of our 25-foot wheelchair ramp
refusing to come inside so he was
outside that's strange because he was
doing great in his training and he knew
to come when called ASAP
I remember getting frustrated with him
as this is very out of character the
light from our solar spotlight was dim
and I looked at my dog something was off
about his appearance his hind legs
suddenly seemed taller than his back
legs wait aren't those the same thing
front legs I think they mean his hind
legs seemed taller than his front legs
but they wrote back legs okay so he used
tipping down or he's like I think his
butt okay all right I mean for the
record any any ghost story involving a
dog barking I'm already scared and I
noticed I couldn't see his normally
he tail wagging it literally never stops
wagging he stood there barking at me and
his bark sounded off - okay it sounded
almost as if a human was trying to
imitate a dog bark
stop stop stop I'm giving John was a
good imitation but it was not a dog bark
I figured all this was just due to my
tired stay and my lack of caffeine in my
system I started to slowly walk down the
ramp when suddenly I heard my dog behind
me clawing at the back door trying to
get out he was snarling I had never
heard him snarl and I have not heard
this from him since it was then I
realized something was wrong and I went
inside and locked the door I honestly
thought it was just beyond the point of
exhaustion however the hair on the back
of his neck was standing straight up
ever see a long-haired golden retriever
have hair standing on on end he looks
scary even to me and I'm his handler I
went to my computer after this and
logged out went to bed I just could not
deal with it the entire night my dog
laid on my feet on the bed not moving it
was not until I listened to a few of
your native legends that I realized this
I was not crazy I finally broke down and
told my husband of the occurrence and
the first thing he said to me is that
was a skinwalker
my husband is native Native American and
grew up hearing stories about things
that go bump in the night
scares me to think about even to this
day true story I need closure can you
please Google what a skinwalker is
because that is so in Navajo culture a
skinwalker is the type of harmful witch
who has the ability to turn in to
possess or disguise himself as an animal
the term is not used for healers for
healers okay the picture of it looks
like an elk that's sort of a skeleton I
had a weird night animals associated
with witchcraft usually include
tricksters such as the coyote but can
include other creatures usually those
associated with death or bad omens
skinwalker stories are told
among Navajo children may be complete
life and death struggles that in and end
in either skinwalker or Navajo killing
the other or partial encounter story
Vandana stalemate so that's I a thousand
percent believe that a thousand percent
because I know that like Native American
burial grounds are like some of the most
haunted creepy scary stuff goes on yeah
creepy is healthy but like a lot of it
like I've never heard of a skinwalker
but a lot of it is like like even where
I grew up there are places where you
could go and like you know it's extra
scary or you're like sitting this
certain but like place and then
allegedly someone will push you you know
yeah a lot of it is like if you're going
there with the intention of like messing
around something will mess with you back
but I did not know that that included
lore of things that just walked around
and scared the [ __ ] out of you hmm
creepy for sure okay anytime that a dog
is barking at something I'm like I
believe you without that's the first
thing anytime they bark is something
that's not a parent that's the first
thing you go to you're like oh man is
there like a spirit or what the hell's
happening cuz they're in tune with [ __ ]
that we're not in kids to kids and
animals no not kids barking like kids
that would probably also be something of
concern kids seemed stuff and like
talking to people that aren't there that
aren't like their imaginary friend like
a thousand believe them thousand percent
believe them hmm
that is terrifying NEP creepy well now
I'm scared of skinwalkers thanks for
that feeling hey welcome this one is
called
the clown in the woods so I'm a police
officer well so by the way I haven't
read this one I read the skinwalker one
okay okay and some of these are written
poorly like this first sentence so I'm a
police officer well special constable to
be truthful nobody's on the woods
will my will might stay with me for life
mmm-hmm
I was working the night shift two nights
ago downtown in the city center okay for
a Friday night yeah this is wow it was
bad
there's just no commas appears it was
bad members of the public getting drunk
also starting fights after the bars had
closed hey hey what people that get
drunk at bars they're not bad members of
the public okay we like fun I had only
just gotten back out to the
station after taking a young male around
the age of 16 who had been underage
drinking okay after taking him to the
station and getting back on patrol after
doing the paperwork on him I was good it
was a good two and a half hours after
getting back out and nothing what
happening happening happy nothing
happening I got a call from control
telling me that there was a 999 call and
the caller said that he was in the woods
what's the 999 probably similar to the
same nine let's see we love it meaning
I'm emergency telephone number in a
number of countries okay so it's just
not like 9-1-1 outside the US of A good
so this might not be in the United
States mm-hmm so he's called to the
woods but when I got there and cut off
my sirens but kept my blue emergency
lights on flashing along with my
headlights this is really really
difficult to read and getting to the end
of the woods there was a building after
getting to the after getting to the
building and not seeing anyone I
contacted my control room and told them
that it might just be a prank called in
by the youths or the youth and was going
to check the building out if I I'm just
gonna read this and if needed stay with
them until their mother and father slash
care comes back and tell them why I am
there as soon as I got out of my car and
only being crude alone so he didn't have
a partner that's scary as it is because
I walk in responding to a call and
walked up to the door notice I'm sick
today can't come in I notice there was a
song coming from within the building
along with laughing I knocked on the
door and someone turned down the song
and the door slowly opened when I went
into the building and checked everywhere
could not see a single person that's
when I was about to leave the building
when I saw 9 or 10 people dressed up as
clowns all holding hunting knives near
the back door so this is in England
actually yep this being England and me
not being able to carry a weapon on my
person
seeing them all have knives I ran to my
car all the while reaching on my radio
emergency button on top and getting no
response from control room back at HQ I
got back in my car revved out of the
woods and drove away still trying to
reach help when I remembered my phone
and called 999 told the operator who I
was she pulled me through the police and
the control room was asking why I wasn't
answering my radio before I could
explain I heard an explosion and saw
smoke and fire coming from the woods
where I told control what had just
happened they told me to keep every to
keep everyone back and the fire services
are on their way as they speak after the
fire services put out the fire I went I
went in to see for myself and I saw the
building the clowns were in and a little
note that read happy Halloween Pig
signed killer Miller [ __ ]
so that was very hard to decipher I was
trying my best but sounded like he went
to a call to this abandoned lay like
building walked inside saw ten people
dressed as clowns with knives sprinted
that got the [ __ ] out of there
what the building blew up the building
and left a note saying
happy Halloween Pig say cool
that's a scary story because it's not
like paranormal or supernatural it's
like very real it's just like people
being terrible mm-hmm those are always
fun I believe that as well yeah right I
mean there are people out there who just
really don't like cops mmm there was
also so I was reading through and there
was this like like because I was
searching through reddit a bunch those
scary stories and one of them was like
the kid is upstairs in his bedroom
calling this parent and he's like I
think something's in my closet and then
they go check in the closet and the kids
in the closet and he's like there's
something in my bed Oh what the [ __ ]
yeah it's good right don't do that all
right let's try this one this one's
called tall tales
okay I used to work at Goodwill as you
can guess I met a lot of fun interesting
people there honestly it felt like I was
gathering new weird toys by the day new
weird stories by the day sorry and soon
things just stopped phasing me here are
a few of my favorite stories I'll top my
head so there's multiple okay
one I just arted working at Goodwill and
had been there maybe a week when a young
man drove up to the donation center I
didn't pay much mind to him until a
co-worker who if you asked me he was a
little off her rocker came running up to
me shouting complete no no bad teeth I
tell her to slow down tell me what was
going on apparently the young man in the
truck was a guy I went to high school
with who had just been charged with Wow
raping a 16 year old girl in the park it
sent chills down my spine because it was
that was then when I realized horrible
people aren't just the people you read
about in the news though the people you
go to school with okay this is to make
matters worse my coworker right now the
donation doors begin shouting
obscenities okay that's not really
spooky that's just like horrible that's
just horrible hmm
let's go on to the next one let's go to
this one actually the mysterious
disappearance of Brandon Lawson yeah I'm
all set was stories really bad below is
some information I was able to so
there's a lot of threads on this on this
story but this is this seemed to be like
the longest most comprehensive one I
could find
Brandon Lawson was a 26 year old man
from San Angelino Texas he was an
oilfield worker and a father of four
children he also had a comma Oh 26 he's
got four kids he was also he had a
common-law wife named Liddell often fun
but you should put a ring on her finger
Brandon he's described as being 5 foot 9
inches tall and weighing approximately
230 pounds Caucasian male with brown
hair and blue eyes Lawson has multiple
tattoos on his arms and a scar on his
chin and left knee one of his ears is
pierced at the time of his disappearance
Lawson was wearing a yellow shirt
camouflage print shorts and white 2013
Air Max shoes August 8 2013 was the last
time Brandon was seen in San Angelino
Texas he and a longtime girlfriend his
longtime girlfriend got into an argument
which led to Brandon leaving the home
around 11:50 4 p.m. with the intentions
of going to his father's
residents approximately 45 minutes later
Brandon calls it calls his brother Kyle
to tell him that he had run out of gas
what is known is that following his
phone call to his brother Kyle something
happened and Brendan phone 911 and
advised the dispatcher that he was in a
field needed help and that he needed a
cop
the dispatcher heard Brendan say I ran
into somebody and responded to him
ran into them ok another call was made
to 911 by a passerby trucker regarding
Brandon's truck parked crooked on the
side of the road posing a hazard Kyle
and his girlfriend Audrey went out to
bring Brandon his gascon Kyle and his
girlfriend phoned 'la Desa to tell her
that Brandon had run out of gas and that
he needed their gas can
Ledesma told him that she would not
leave this is Larissa told him she would
not leave on the porch as she was going
to have a shower ok that's a Brandon's
girlfriend yes ok yeah common-law
partner Kyle
Kyle's checks however did not clear in
his bank account so he had no money to
fill the gas and figured when he got to
Brandon he could just drive him to
stripes convenient market and Brandon
would pay for the gas himself the truck
was located on u.s. 227 four and a half
miles south of Bronte Texas and close to
a rest stop by the time Kyle arrived
around 1:10 a.m. on August 9th there was
no sign of Brandon there was also a
sheriff's deputy that had arrived at the
truck about the same time as Kyle and
Audrey there was no visit over an hour
later a cop got to him over an hour just
before midnight so they arrived in the
cops already there there was no visible
damage to Brandon's truck and his keys
and cell phone were all missing it's
understood that the deputy that the
deputy nor Kyle were aware that Brandon
phone 9 when went asking for a cop as
well as stating please hurry huh while
talking with the deputy Kyle received a
call from Brandon in which Brandon's
cell was going in and out and he was
hard to understand
Brannen claimed that he was ten minutes
up the road he also mentioned that he
was bleeding the phone went dead at this
point
what kyle understood was I'm in the
field Kyle felt maybe Brandon was hiding
in the field due to an outstanding
warrant from two years ago that Brandon
himself just learned he was going to
address the following week so Kyle made
no mention the deputy or Brandon being
on the phone so he was too proud trying
trying to cover for him in case he was
gonna get arrested
so basically Kyle talks to him doesn't
tell the cop had Kyle known Brandon
phone 9-1-1 he would have never assumed
his brother was hiding so that's crazy
mm-hmm so he didn't even know his
brother called the cops it was confirmed
that the gas tank was in fact empty his
cell phone was a Motorola Droid Razr
there was an extensive search of the
area which turned up no sign of him
however he has never been heard from
again
Lawson's family were unaware he called
9-1-1 that night and only found out when
they viewed his cellular phone records
around 118 audrey cents brandon a
texting a cop is at your truck it is
assumed she did so to warn him because
of his warrant at this time they were
not aware that he himself called 9-1-1
and said please hurry and statements
given to the police as explained by the
family they did admit Brent earlier call
to them in which he told his brother and
Audrey that he was 10 minutes up the
road and was bleeding this was also not
reported to deputy Neil at the scene
it's understood that deputy Neil did not
report to Kyle that Brandon phone 911 so
nobody was talking to each other here
the cop didn't say hey your brother
called the cops and they're and they're
withholding the fact that they received
a call from him on the spot mm-hmm
from from all media reports written by
the observer enterprise which happens to
be owned by the sheriff and his wife the
9-1-1 call was only reported as a
stranded motorist who ran out of gas
there was no mention of urgency nor any
mentions afraid of the phrase I ran into
them as understood by the dispatcher the
deputy then put emergency flashers on
locked the truck and proceeded to leave
the scene and arranged for a tow in the
morning according to reports the deputy
did drive up and down the freeway
or the highway to see if he could spot
brain and walking Kyle and his
girlfriend left the empty gas can by
beside the truck thinking if Brandon
came back he would at least have the can
to retrieve gas they began to go look
for him it was the following morning
that there was still no sign of Brandon
Kyle's money was now available in his
account he went back to the truck and
filled the can and returned it to the
truck at this point he was now starting
to become concerned and felt that
Brandon may not have been hiding and may
actually be in trouble in talking with
investigators he now gave them the full
account of Brandon being on the phone
with them at the time the deputy was at
the truck it wasn't known by Brandon's
family that he called 911 until
Brandon's common-law wife the Desa saw
on the itemized cell phone transactions
provided by law enforcement that a 9-1-1
call was made there's been no activity
on Brandon's bank accounts or cell phone
since that time an extensive search was
conducted by professional search and
rescue October 24 2013 around the area
of the abandoned truck Brandon's family
doesn't believe that the outstanding
felony felony warrant is connected to
his disappearance any disappearance and
he believes that he would not have run
from the police because of it he worked
in the oil industry at the time of his
disappearance and left behind four
children three with his girlfriend one
with a prior relationship although
investigators have stated that there was
no evidence of foul play in this case
his family stated it's uncharacteristic
of him to leave without warning and
they're afraid for his safety he's
classified as an involuntary miss
involuntarily missing person and the
case remains unsolved over the years
there have been many false information
information put out by the media here
are just a few examples law enforcement
concludes man not in Coke County the
statement is ludicrous just because
Brandon hasn't been found yet doesn't
mean he's somehow no longer in the
county members of members of Texas
search and rescue and various law
enforcement agencies begin arriving last
Wednesday evening for Thursday's massive
search for Brandon Lawson the latest
items sorry the latest search stems from
the incident that occurred just before
1:00 a.m. on Friday she fails to mention
that the particular 9-1-1 call was made
by a passing motorist a trucker who
thought Brandon's truck was parked on
safely on the street
okay so that's kind of it and it remains
unsolved Wow I don't know I thought that
was going somewhere kind of else but
that's crazy though yeah I mean this was
posted a 1 year ago and that's all the
updates they have it's crazy like cuz
you're expecting something wild but this
is like a real story mm-hmm you know
what the [ __ ] did what does his family
thing happened in I don't know man
I'm reading through the comments it's
kind of wild few questions was Brandon a
felon if he was did he own a gun legally
or illegally if he usually had a gun in
his truck was the gun abandoned in the
truck or wasn't missing well I think the
whole point of them like not the whole
miscommunication about the phone call
tonight on one is that if someone has an
outstanding warrant and they're aware of
it you have to be in a real emergency in
order to call 911 so they were sort of
covering for him because the cop was
there then they realized that he
actually had called 911 like you're
you're you're giving up everything you
have at that point of you know not
getting arrested you're getting arrested
after you get help
you don't mean yeah so he was in a very
serious situation that he called the
cops
hmm he was bleeding in the field like he
must have wrought a gas right yeah
piercing they'd be surprised if he
didn't have a gun something happened to
him on the side of the road hmm and then
where do you go I don't know it's weird
that there's there's been no report of
like a body found or anything like that
that's that's creepy to me but that
isn't that like serial killer people do
[ __ ] like that
I'm sorry that sounds so dumb what but
like aren't there plenty of people who
have died from you know their car breaks
down and then someone offers to help
them and just does really fucked-up [ __ ]
to them or is that just all movies no
that's like that's some real
I've read stories about hitchhikers that
are just like there was one story I read
on they're not even hitchhikers like
someone pretending that they're gonna
come help you fix your car because your
car is broken down yeah gnarly or people
having a trap set up where their car is
broken down right well yeah I read
something on reddit recently because I
was reading through these threads and
one of them was like one of the scary
stories I have is like we drove me and
my wife drove by this hitchhiker and I
remember thinking to myself I'm never
gonna pick that hedge I grew up no way
like not only is just on principle but
it's just scary looking person mm-hmm
and they read in the news the next week
that that murdered somebody like a car
that picked them up my god we're victims
yeah me and my mom used to pick people
up sometimes when I was younger but they
were like women with children and
waiting in a bus stop and my mom
occasionally would go like if it was
raining or snowing or something she'd
really can I give you a ride somewhere
I remember a couple times then being
like you know it's this woman with her
you know 11 year old daughter and they'd
be like you seem like you're not trying
to do anything mom's like I'm really not
I'm just trying to give you a ride
you're waiting in the rain or the snow
at the bus stop yeah but like that's
about it a woman and a child picking up
another woman and a child you know I I
don't think I could ever pick some up on
the side of the road and be like this is
this is safe I don't do you imagine
being like an uber driver though
especially at night or even a person
riding in and over everything's scary
what the hell super weird dude crazy
[ __ ] this is like the thing about the
real stories is some of them don't have
that shock factor as some of the like
fictional ones but if you think about
them they're like oh my god it's really
scary
there's a thread here about people who
spend time outdoors like campers and
hikers and stuff and what's the scariest
encounter with another person with
another person yeah
oh my god can we read some yeah you want
to yeah I thought you were gonna be like
oh with wildlife or like weird noises or
bears or with other people are you
[ __ ] kidding me yeah alright go off
so um I got woken up and this one's
short I got woken up at night by a park
ranger I'm assuming they're camping
yelling for us to get out of our car get
into our car oh [ __ ] alright so they got
woken up out of their campsite by a park
ranger saying get in your car a grizzly
had eaten a woman in her tent one sight
over and they had not found the bear yet
oh my god another time I was pulled over
by police shortly after I left a
campground I was driving a van a man had
murdered four people in the camp in the
same campground that I was at and the
police thought that he was in my van
forcing me to drive him away through the
use of a machete that he was wielding as
soon as I stopped the cop opened the
door grabbed my arm and yanked me out he
thought I was like a hostage and he was
saving my life oh my god this [ __ ]
guy's been through it god damn Jesus
that's terrifying yep I love camping I
feel like all the joy has just been
sucked out of it so quickly mm-hmm went
on a day camping trip with my friend
with my friend and her boyfriend that
she had recently met on the Internet
lit we are in the middle of nowhere in
Montana not a soul around no cell
reception I'm not from Montana so I
don't really know where the [ __ ] we are
dude is way bigger than either she or I
am or both pretty small the creepiness
starts when we're driving around
off-roading and my friend's moms truck
looking for a place to park and set up
camp my friend's boyfriend is driving we
come across a potential spot and she and
I get out to scope
now while we're doing this he backs up
the truck and starts to drive away I
turn to my friend and say what the [ __ ]
is he doing she starts to run after him
waving him down he finally stops about a
quarter mile and lets us in he doesn't
say anything he just brushes it off as
well he must have not liked that spot so
they don't think anything of it what we
find a different spot up the road and
this time I wait until he gets out of
the car before I get out I tell my
friend that she should hold onto the
keys he starts getting real quiet and
sulky and won't help us set up camp then
he starts walking away in one direction
without saying a word and just keeps
walking my friend runs after him to
catch up and ask him if everything is ok
when she catches him and stops to catch
her breath he turns around and starts
walking the other direction without
saying a word to her he comes back onto
the site and starts rolling around and
they on the ground in the dirt at this
point I was like ok we need to go she
says everything is fine and I'm ruining
the trip I not good attitude I'm trying
to get along yeah he keeps rolling and
acting bizarre so she finally agrees to
leave he's still the one driving as
we're headed back out of nowhere he
stops the truck and just sits there and
he gets out of the truck starts walking
around a pile of rocks and wood I tell
her that if he does anything that makes
me seriously think he's gonna hurt us I
have pepper spray and I won't hesitate
to use it eventually he gets back in the
truck and mumbles something about
wanting to check it out just wanting to
check it out he didn't kill us and
nothing else happened but I felt really
freakin vulnerable out there in the
middle of nowhere with no one but my
delusional friend and this creepy
Internet stranger it actually cost us
our friendship because she didn't want
to see that there was anything wrong
with anything that happened that day and
she couldn't wait to see him again hmm
fun that sounds like such a fun day trip
that sounds like that sounds like drugs
there's literally all these comments
header like drugs drugs God nope I'm all
set we can do true creepy people stories
I like creepy people but not the ones
that scare me just ones that are like a
little weird let's see I see the titles
yeah I don't wanna like the only thing
about this site that's kind of [ __ ] is
that sorts by like recent instead of top
so I can't there's no way to like
[Music]
disturbing hmmm almost kidnapped okay
let's read this one man on the road it
was 11:00 at night o ni te and I was my
friend Tracey's house I decided that I
should head home before my dad got home
my dad liked salsa dancing and would go
dancing late into the night he usually
got home around midnight
oh you dad like that have a good time
tres lived in a different neighborhood
than me his neighborhood was connected
to mine by a road that gay people
existed this is rough gave people
exiting the highway access to our
neighborhoods and people from our
neighborhoods access to that way I began
my walk it was a nice night and I
enjoyed the walk I was soon on the front
road and had that had thick woods maybe
10 to 20 feet off the road and a large
hill half a mile down the road it made
it to where you could only see cars from
a half-mile away I was looking around
when I sound another man on the side of
the highway he appeared to be looking at
me so I continued to stare at him when
we were both parallel to one another he
made a mad dash across the highway there
were no cars driving down the highway
one of which there were no cars driving
down the front roads
one on the highway it slammed on its
horn nearly hitting him he was unfazed
and continued his sprint towards me so
he's across the road in Sprint's or
Sprint's towards person who I think is a
girl seeing this I began to turn Ryan
away from him after a couple seconds of
running I looked back to see that he was
still indeed chasing me my heart sank
and my run turned into a mad dash down
the center of the road off in the
distance I saw lights from a car as it
got closer I slowed standing in mill the
road and turned around to see my pursuer
but no one was there I sighed and
stepped to the side of the road began to
walk feeling pretty stupid telling
myself I made it all up as I was walking
I heard the shuffle of feet behind me I
turned around and saw the man only now
he was less than 20 feet away from me
and running at me he was instantly
covered I was instantly covered in a
cold sweat and every time my heart beat
it felt as though I was sending razors
down my body my feet were moving so
quickly I could barely manage not to
trip over them when I turned onto my
neighborhood Street I yelled help help
help as loud as I could to my relief the
man did not continue his pursuit into
the neighborhood I looked around and
noticed the only one person came out to
help me I look at him waved it waved and
then went home at least I got home
before my dad did from salsa dancing
these are creepy these are creepy
because like I don't know I was weird
I think it's just some weird weird
stories I'm scared
where I'm scared cuz some of the
scariest things in life are just other
people mmm that's true some real sickos
out there man mm-hmm okay I can read
this one this one's called this one's on
a thread called what is your true creepy
story cuz you want to stick to the true
ones right yeah my ex-boyfriend it's
about my ex-boyfriend when I was 14 or
15 I dated an older guy at the time I
thought it was cool that an older person
showed interest in me he's very
good-looking and I was quickly in love
looking back it was very creepy and
illegal for me to go out with a 23 year
old I was 14 yeah we dated for like six
months and he was obsessed with me mom
he would not let me go out with my
friends talk to people and he would
message me constantly so I wouldn't
forget that he was in charge of
relationship wow that that's already
incredibly creepy [ __ ] terrible at
one point I couldn't take his obsession
anymore and decided to break up he told
me if I broke up with him he would tell
my parents we were dating my parents are
very strict and I was naive to the world
so I decided to keep dating him he
constantly told me that he would kill
himself
this is way too real well if he had to
live without me sometimes he would I
felt responsible for his life he started
to follow me after class follow me
around town and follow me when I hang on
my friends I felt like your middle
school class I felt in prison I could
not breathe on a particular week and I
lied to my parents and told them I was
sleeping in a friend's house I was not
supposed to sleep in my ex's house and
he took me to a party with him I got
very drunk and I just couldn't deal with
him anymore the alcohol killed my
inhibition and I broke up with him he
started to yell at me in front of
everyone and a girl I did not know saved
me from him she told me she would take
me home and promised me I would be safe
my ex followed the girls car the entire
time I was terrified he was going to
kill me as he followed the car he called
my parents and told them that I went to
a party and got drunk he forgot to
mention that we were dating and that he
was the one exposing me to alcohol once
home I explained everything to my
parents long story short my ex got
charged with sexual misconduct with a my
sexual conduct with a minor and stalking
I was just a child but to this day I
still struggle trusting people oh my god
Jesus Christ that's terrifying when you
learn more about skinwalkers oh my god
okay yeah I guess so happy Halloween Oh
actually I want to see if there's a oh
boo skinwalker story okay this is like a
whole dedicated like thing just
skinwalkers yeah I think so well I mean
oh yeah oh my god yeah the idea of
seeing something that sounds like a dog
and then you get closer and it sounds
like something imitating a dog makes me
actually like wanna vomit like it hits
me in some weird visceral place that I
just want to [ __ ] throw up mm-hmm
the story about a skinwalker okay my
wife and I were driving through the
northern Arizona Highway 89 between Oh
Arizona's possi year you think we have a
skinwalker see between 5-7 page it was
about 1:00 a.m. we were on the third
shift of our time and often drove at
night to avoid traffic
I saw a few sets of eyes glowing in my
headlights a little ways up the road so
I let off the gas slowing down to avoid
hitting an animal on the road when we
drove by we saw several dogs or coyotes
on the side of the road and I hit the
grep and I hit the gas and drove by
after we passed my wife said that one of
them was running next to the car what
are you just checking in one of the
Coyotes was running next to the car I
looked over and saw it as well probably
20 feet off the shoulder of the road I
floored it and looked over and it stood
up on its hind legs and kept pace with
us for a couple seconds before turning
away oh my god I didn't a coyote just
standing up and then running next to
your car
nope this whole event probably lasted no
more than 10 seconds but it was
seriously the most terrifying 10 seconds
of my life
damn what this is that I decided that
skinwalkers there's some of the scariest
things that I've heard of aside from Lee
just pure demons hey are you okay yeah
Kermit would you park it a skinwalker
for me
probably not you probably cry at it and
ask it for food huh um do you want me to
read a longer one about skinwalkers yeah
they're the scariest ones I've never
told this story to anyone and I don't
really intend to tell it again I have a
pounding migraine today and this threat
has kept me good company as I've drifted
in just real quick
do we have any sponsors what yeah yeah
sorry it's okay episode's brought to you
by the farmers dog not skinwalkers it's
almost 40 minutes in sorry I got a
little distracted with the skinwalkers
guys isn't it crazy that so many of us
have careful are careful about the food
that we ourselves eat but our dogs
versus like hey you know eat whatever no
farmer's dog says that's a bad idea
the farmer's dog is a company that helps
deliver dogs better fresh and delicious
food for them we can attest to this like
our dogs will be so dazzled about eating
sometimes and when we switch to the
farmers dog they started to go nuts at
feeding time
marbles specifically so basically the
farmers dog is a totally different way
to feed your dog you go on to the
farmers dog calm answer some questions
about your pet and a vet developed a
meal plan is created just for your dog
specifically and then when they deliver
it to your house it has like their name
on the package and everything it's
really nice the food arrives at your
door and pre-portioned packs ready to
open and pour it's easy to feed them you
don't have to heat it or cook it or
anything it's all it's all done
and Food Matters guys studies show that
even adding fresh food to your dog's
diet can reduce cancer risk by 90%
personally I enjoy because they eat much
easier and they're not whiny about the
food we're feeding them they love it and
eat it fast it's a they very very up the
the meals enough for people to for your
dogs to want to keep interest so when
you do the farmers dog they basically
create a meal plan and it lasts for
however long you want to do it for they
deliver the packages on a regular
schedule to your house and you just pop
them in feed them and they're good to go
right now you guys can start feeding
your dogs better to get 50 percent off
your first two week trial of fresh
healthy food by going to the farmer's
dog comments th e fa RM ers do G comm
slash annejulien
and you get free shipping my 1zb wants
me to open it and put them inside it
know how it works but check it out guys
hit the link in our description and
treat your dog to some good food also
guys if you're thinking about building a
website Squarespace is the best way to
do it if you need a domain website or
online store doula Squarespace Pixar
lifts air walk Michigan Nike all those
big brands created their sites with
Squarespace now you can get yours
started there templates and options for
templates are amazing
you'd be surprised by how many different
like builds you can start your website
with without doing any work at all they
have amazing templates and my favorite
part about Squarespace is the 24/7
customer support award-winning customer
support no matter what late hour of the
night you're building your website they
are there to help you with it
in my opinion that's what makes
Squarespace stand out internet hours
yeah so if you're ready to start your
own business guys do with Squarespace
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and right now when you go to
squarespace.com slash annejulien you get
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain squ a RESP AC e comm slash
annejulien check it out and click the
link below and you guys will be on your
way
thank you sponsor Reggie sponsors
from it you want to hear about
skinwalkers yeah I'm like these are
really scary to me hmm yeah skinwalkers
are creepy I had never heard of them
before this podcasts yeah me neither
okay this one's kind of long let's do it
when I was 10 I lived with my mother we
were below poverty level we were poor we
lived up in the mountains around Santa
Cruz my mother had a friend my mother
had a friend that owned a large bit of
property up there and he led us this is
mom and he let us stay in a trailer our
trailer was very small and it was right
beside a garden a chain-link fence ran
around the garden to keep the dog in the
owner the dog that the owner had out of
the garden along with other animals deer
and things are very common in the area
also inside the fence area was a single
room it was built like a tiny house but
it was only one single room on the
inside the room had electricity and
since our actual trailer didn't we spent
a lot of our time in that room I was
super into video games there was one
thing you should know right now this
small fenced in area was only a small
part of the property most of it was
heavily forested also I refused to leave
the fenced area because the owners dog
had been mistreated by children in the
past and was very sketchy towards me all
the time poor dog if I was alone it
would bite at me even through the fence
the fence was tall at least 7 feet high
and wasn't movable so as long as the
gate was closed I was safe that said
tiny bit of the property was where we
were yeah there's no one else around
from house and Osmo so there's just a
lot of acres of woods on the property
now I tell you all this because I think
it's important you understand what kind
of scene this was before I really get
into the story we have a fenced-in
location that seems fairly safe and it
contains a trailer in a single room with
power that's not connected to the
trailer nothing around for miles
my mom's van is parked out front of the
gate to the fenced area and not a single
unpaved and one single unpaved road
leads from the garden for about a mile
to the main house so they're a mile away
from the property house the huge thing
with now I brought friends up there to
sleep over here and there we all thought
it was pretty cool kind of like camping
out besides we would get our own room to
stay in and play video games all night
it was like a dream come true the
downside was simple when it got dark out
it got really dark out no city around
and the trailer would not be lit up
there was no bathroom to use in the room
so you would have to walk out into the
dark garden in order to get the trailer
get to the trailer to use it odd things
kept happening from from time to time it
was always something that could be
somewhat easily explained a way though
noises like people working at night
sometimes or once me and a friend were
sitting out in the garden and we saw a
shadow as big as a small bear bound up a
tree but the tree didn't shake like
there was weight on it
the dog also creeped me out you know an
angry dog and I was a kid that's pretty
normal now I'm a scaredy cat I always
have been to be honest I don't know why
I even come to this subreddit I have
trouble walking through the lit house if
I'm all alone my friends however tend to
be more outgoing just that kinds of
people I get along with this time I had
friends over this one friend he okay
his name was Jacob we were staying up
all night and playing Sonic the Hedgehog
300 yeah and Knuckles on my Sega Genesis
on an old ratty television we started
playing as the Sun went down and by the
time we were finishing up the game it
was about 2:00 a.m. that's when we heard
it we turned off the game getting ready
to find something else to play and there
was a rumbling in the woods behind the
room we were in
like somebody was rolling something
really heavy around on the ground we
hadn't heard it before because the noise
from what we were playing was loud like
the video game itself like the TV was
loud when we heard it immediately I got
goose bumps
Jakob was not really worried by it but
it's not like there was someone else's
house or yard right over there
it was forest for miles and it sounded
like someone was constructing something
or dragging or rolling something really
big eventually Jakob convinced me to
just play some more games I agree
on the condition that we turn the volume
up so we didn't so sorry turn the volume
down okay so we could hear [ __ ] we
started playing no turn that [ __ ] oh I
ain't trying to hear that
[ __ ] it off scary [ __ ] in the woods turn
that [ __ ] uh we started playing and I
didn't even notice the noise stop
because I was getting engrossed a couple
hours later Jacob said he had to use the
bathroom which they have to watch from
the room through the dark trailer get a
water bottle or something
I was feeling fine by then so I was fine
when he left to the trailer to relieve
himself he was taking a while so
eventually I decided to go back on and
check on him besides I could use the
bathroom and grab a snack while I was at
it I opened the door to leave and he was
just standing at the doorway right
outside facing it scared the [ __ ] out of
me I asked him what he was doing and he
just stood there blocking the exit I
realized he must have sneaked up to the
door because I could not hear I didn't
hear anything and I could hear him walk
away from the room but I hadn't heard
him walk back up to it okay I'm gonna
throw up
it was super quiet no noises from a city
no houses I should have just been able
to hear it but I couldn't he refused to
say anything I respond he just stood
there I told him he was being really
creepy but it was not unlike him to try
and scare me like this finally I decided
to just go to the trailer and use the
bathroom myself partially because I knew
my mother was asleep in there I told him
what I was doing then moved past him
when I pushed him out of the way his
skin felt freezing to the touch I jumped
a little bit but it was a cold night and
we had been he had been standing out
there for probably thirty minutes so I
figured that was to be expected I walked
as quick as I could over to the trailer
he followed me like right on my tail it
was very unnerving I joked a little
saying he already surprised me by
scaring me at the door that joke is over
finally I arrived at the trailer and I
walk in he didn't follow just stated the
doorway I checked on my mom who was fast
asleep and turned to go to the bathroom
now it being a porta potty we keep the
bathroom door shut because it smell
and when I reach for the door and try to
open it it's locked a very nervous voice
came from behind the door I'm in here
I quickly turned to look at Jacob but
the door was still open and there was
nothing out there but pitch-black night
I freeze in terror I would have heard
the bathroom I just got chills I would
have heard the bathroom door open if if
he had come in behind me and gone that
way there was no way he would have done
it quietly it creaks like a [ __ ]
I yelped so loud that my mom woke up
startled I stared at the doorway unable
to bring myself to move a muscle
she got up walked over there and looked
out not seeing anything she closed the
door and asked me what the hell is wrong
by now Jacob was coming out of the
bathroom and acting perfectly normal but
a bit confused I explained what had
happened Jacob said he was taking a long
time in the bathroom basically neither
of them believed me no matter how much I
insist of what I saw my mom is sure that
I just got sleepy and imagined it Jacob
thought I was trying to prank him so my
mom gets out a big flashlight walks us
back to the room tells us to go to sleep
and leaves and goes back to the bed
herself the room doesn't have any
windows or anything so after a while I
come back down telling myself that my
mom was right I must have had a weird
walking dream or something Jacob but
[ __ ] was in the bathroom the whole time
and I'm inclined to believe him because
there's no way to really get around
without being heard so I settle down I'm
a little rattled but I'm thinking like
maybe I can just sleep this off and get
through the night suddenly the dog just
starts going no okay right behind us the
room is up against the fence the dog
must have been like right behind the
room on the other side I felt like I
jumped so high I was surprised and hit
the roof Jacobs laughing at me like ha
dog barking at a squirrel or some [ __ ]
and you're [ __ ] yourself it keeps
going like that for a long time though
suddenly the barking stops and gets
replaced by whimpering no you hear the
dog run away there's about 40 seconds of
silence before we hear something new a
small scratching sound on the back wall
of the room
we both try to be as silent as we can
and eventually it stops after five
minutes or so of silence Jacob decides
to be brave he insists he's going out to
go get my mother up tell her something
Crazy's going on we're gonna go from
there with some kind of divine adult
protection protection no doubt I wish he
wouldn't leave me alone but there's no
way I'm going out there never ever
he arms himself as best he could he
could with a tennis racquet that we had
in the room with us he takes a couple
deep breaths opens the door and dashes
out I close it as quickly as I can
behind him in less than 30 seconds I
hear a scream not long after the door
flies open II comes back in looking pale
as a ghost he's breathing like he just
ran a marathon and his eyes look as big
as dinner plates I asked what's going on
like four times before he could get some
words out he tells me he walked out
there and as he was walking through the
garden as quick as he could he saw my
mom just standing there he tried to talk
to her but she stared at him with a
blank expression getting super creeped
out because of what had happened to me
earlier he took a couple more steps
towards her telling her that he thought
something was in the woods
suddenly her her face turned into an
awkward smile then he realized something
terrible
he hadn't noticed sooner because the
darkness of how much of a hurry he'd
been in but she was on the other side of
the fence now the door to this room does
not lock and as I explained earlier the
room had no windows he had been trying
to move stuff in front of the door as he
told this story but by the end I was
helping him in retrospect whatever was
harassing us he seems to be adverse to
actually entering the room or trailer
because the Jacob one didn't come in
right and he could have and this room
was not sturdy
either way we stacked everything we
could against the door thinking somehow
like cartoons that this would totally
definitely keep the creatures out for
the rest of the night we heard scratches
coming from all around the room I cried
Jacob looking like his mind had left his
body with fear at one point he thought I
thought I heard it speak to
I heard it from right next to where I
was resting against the wall with my
mother's voice quietly the same phrasing
and intonation she had used earlier in
the night what's wrong followed by and
immediately go to sleep the son must
have come up eventually the scratching
eventually stopped and we heard my mom
come to get us
this time actually hearing footsteps we
absolutely refused to leave the room my
mom had to go to the property owner and
have him take the door off when we saw
it was actually her I burst into tears
again we had never had any experiences
like these again and eventually we moved
away but that night still haunts me I
refuse to go out at night unless I'm
with a bunch of people and we'll never
live in the woods again oh my god oh boy
that was that was worth it that was a
good one that is terrifying yep so that
was a skinwalker well it looks like that
was one skinwalker manifesting in
different forms
to terrorize or to encounter one person
I like the lure of the skinwalker that
they take the form of something else and
that they're like tricksters and
shapeshifters and witches or whatever do
when when when they see the mom as it
goes as the night what is it a
skinwalker and she's on the other side
of the fence I can't get out with a clam
with an awkward grin I'm all set I'm all
set with the dog barking and then
whimpering and then scratching at the
house I'm all set I'm just all set damn
dude
that was gnarly that was gnarly
literally all set yeah that was good I
don't got me going and that's in
California I'm upset mm-hmm I want there
to be no skinwalkers here I don't want a
chance of seeing one I really don't the
[ __ ] is that supposedly evidence a
creepy figure behind that thing
I don't like any of it oh god that looks
like a ooh that's creepy you'd think
that they were probably unable to be
captured on camera or whatever I have no
idea
goddamn this whole subreddit it's like
accounts of people saying I'm pretty
sure I saw skinwalker read another one
no I read that one
[Music]
all right it was trying to lure me into
the woods oh cool
background I'm a female and this
occurred two years ago when I was 18
takes place in Ag yeah every summer my
family and I'd go up to camp in the
Dedham Ellsworth Maine it's about three
hour drive from my house and the camp
itself is about an hour from the nearest
town I've been going to this camp my
entire life my family owns it and we had
never had an incident like this before
happened I was watching TV in the middle
of the night while you're camping it's
like they just went to like a cottage or
something I was watching TV in the
middle of the night both my brothers and
parents had gone to bed
first mistake I heard a noise coming
from the kitchen and realized that the
dogs need to go outside and do their
business so I took my brothers to
pitbulls and my Affenpinscher tiny dog
outside after turning the porch light on
I walked around to the front yard and I
let the dogs off leash it's so
incredibly dark in the woods of Maine
that the poorest I really only
illuminated the porch or nothing else so
I tried to keep an eye on them
I was momentarily distracted when I saw
a loon or a wild bird duck on the lake
they make really pretty noises yeah when
I look back I saw that the pit bulls
were both looking at something in the
woods I couldn't see what it was but I
assumed that they had seen a squirrel or
a raccoon it was then that I realized
they didn't see that I didn't see Alfie
anywhere she was an awfully small dog
and she's completely black I called her
a few times and heard some soft
whimpering right where the dogs had been
looking earlier oh I took a couple
couple steps in that direction and
called for her again worried that she
may have gotten her paw stuck in between
rocks or gotten stuck in a snake hole
suddenly I feel something moving behind
me I whipped around and it was Alfie she
had been staying close to me this whole
time
I just hadn't seen her so naturally I
was thinking if alfie is here with the
Fox in the woods I took another step
forward and the pitbulls begin to growl
they were slowly advancing and we're now
on either side of me looking right into
the blackness of the woods I quickly
pick up Alfie and began to back up very
slowly I'm not sure what was in there
but as are a lot of animals in Maine I
figured the dogs knew better than I
since I couldn't see anything right
right as I turned around I heard the
most absolutely bone-chilling thing I've
ever heard in my life coming from the
direction of the woods I heard something
/ someone call Alfie's name no it
sounded as almost if if it were trying
to mimic me calling off his name moments
earlier but it was all wrong
that the voice sounded really distorted
and almost seemed to wail I freaked the
[ __ ] out ran inside with the dogs to
this day I have no idea what was out in
the woods my camp is essentially a log
cabin overlooking a lake and our nearest
neighbor lives at least a half a mile in
the opposite direction stop skinwalker
stories dude I didn't know these things
were things like this so glad immitating
of the human voices what gets like the
the amount that I've like been camping
out in the woods or like I grew up at my
cottage like all of that I would go
outside in the dark all the time no fear
of anything I like loved it you know I
mean like get occasionally scared if you
thought an animal was there but like if
I had known that that was a thing like
that was like lore that I was aware of
are you [ __ ] kidding me
mm-hmm like I don't want to go outside
anymore yeah thanks skinwalkers TM like
the fact that they like imitate people
and animals is like that makes me sick
to my stomach
yeah the fact that they take the [ __ ]
that they could take the shape of like
you for instance like if I'm out in the
woods we're camping together and you're
in one place but I see you right in
front of me and it's just like a blank
stare on your face that's Ken
skinwalkers hurt yeah cuz according to
the other kids story like it could hurt
a dog but Nava the Navajo believe that
if you lock eyes with a skinwalker they
can tae-sik oh my god I love that I love
that for us some Navajo also believe
that skinwalkers have the ability to
just steal the skin or
body of a person oh oh if you lock eyes
at this Ken Walker they can absorb
themselves into your body oh but maybe
that's how they take the form of like a
person and then they like leave
okay can you read that whole thing
because I'm I'm interested because I
need to know how to defend myself okay
in Native American legends the
skinwalker is a person with a
supernatural ability to turn into any
animal he or she desires it was a person
okay yeah they they must be uh though
they must be wearing a pelt of the
animal to transform similar lore can be
found in cultures throughout the world
and is often often referred to as
shape-shifting by anthropologists Navajo
skinwalker the so in Game of Thrones
what's it called when he's a crow or one
eyed Raven he can change into animals
it's like that but like bran doesn't
have to wear a pelt
yeah and he's not physically there it's
only in his mind like he's transporting
his brain according to this Lord in
conscience is the person alive and they
have to I got to get to it let's see I'm
confused possibly the best-documented
skinwalker beliefs are those relating to
the Navajo Nation ye na blue she
literally with it literally translates
to with it he goes on all fours in the
Navajo language
yeet na blue she was one of several
varieties of Navajo which specifically
sorry which specifically a practitioner
of the witchery way as opposed to a user
of curse objects or a practitioner of
the frenzy way technically the term
refers to aunt Jeannie he who's using
rarely her powers to travel in animal
form and sub versions men or women have
attained the highest level of priesthood
are called quiz yah T or pure evil then
then they commit the act of killing a
member of the family of their own family
God and then they have thus gained the
evil powers that are associated with
skinwalkers the aunt Ginny he are human
beings who have gained super power by
breaking a cultural taboo specifically a
person is said to gain the power to
become enob lu-shi upon initiation into
the witchery way both
women can become that and therefore
become possible skinwalkers but men are
far more numerous it has generally
thought that only childless women can
become witches child this woman although
is more frequent frequently seen as a
coyote wolf owl or fox or crow the yield
ye na blue she is said to have the power
to assume the form of any animal they
choose depending on what kind of
abilities they need witches use a forum
for expedient travel especially the
Navajo equivalent of the black mass a
perverted the black mass a perverted
song and the central rite of witchery
away used to curse instead of to heal
they also may transform to an escape to
escape from pursuers some Navajo also
believe that skinwalkers have the
ability to steal the skin or body of a
person the Navajo believes that if you
lock eyes with a skinwalker they can
absorb themselves into your body it has
also said that skinwalkers avoid the
light and that their eyes glow like
animals do but when in human form so
you're seeing like a glowing wolf Sahai
in a human a skinwalker is usually
described as naked except for an animal
skin some Navajos destructor described
him as a mutilated sorry mutated version
of the animal so like the way the way
that the woman was describing her dog
the hind legs were weird the skin may
just be a mask like those which are the
only garment worn in the witch's song
because animal skins are used primarily
by skin walkers the pelt of animals such
as bears coyotes wolves and cougars are
strictly taboo
sheepskin and buckskin are probably two
of the few hides used by Navajos the
latter is only for ceremonial purposes
legend has it skin walkers can have the
power to read human thoughts they also
possess the ability to make any human or
animal noise that they choose skinwalker
may use the voice of a relative or a cry
of an infant to lure victims out of the
safe do you know know know know know
know know that okay where did I hear
that recently it's been going around on
Twitter that was a thing that I
literally forgot was a thing
so I forget which serial killer it was
had used a recording of an infant crying
to put outside of people's homes to lure
them outside of their house that is so
beyond twist or lure them to the door so
if you're ever home and you hear an
infant crying outside of your door call
the [ __ ] police don't open the door
I forget which serial killer it was but
it was like part of their mo at one
point that's like terrifying and
brilliant yeah [ __ ] so [ __ ]
according to Navajo myth the only way to
successful successfully shoot a
skinwalker is to dip bullets into white
ash okay I don't have bullets or white
ash to shoot a skinwalker to find out
weapons jamming or frozen whoa I want to
read an account of someone trying to
shoot a skinwalker and their gun jams
Yeah right gun jams
skinwalker I need to know more about
them how to protect slash kill
skinwalkers oh my god these people out
here trying to kill quote-unquote
skinwalkers and it's like their
neighbor's cat and Navajo culture has
said that the only way to kill a
skinwalker is to say the witch's name ah
what's their name we supposed to get to
know them before they what the hell Oh
other times if the gun fires the rounds
have no effect if spotted the skinwalker
will run away and if chased his
footprint will not be present even if
only a few feet away also it is if it is
fired at even at point-blank range it
would have no effect and may attack or
run off don't that's scary was a dog I'm
pretty sure that was halo that was halo
but it could have been the skinwalker
pretending to be halo and here halo was
just at our door and we're like hey dude
halo could have been a skinwalker that
hold Carmen are you a skinwalker you
better not I suggest bringing a fistful
of dried sage lighting it and drawing a
circle around your campsite with the
burning sage near you
so just if you're gonna go camping just
sage it real quick because skinwalkers
be like
I'm scared but wait come on I still
don't understand if they can hurt you or
not
well I haven't read many accounts of
them attacking people like what is this
this is very old
most commonly male or skinwalkers this
type of shape-shifting which that uses
enchanted animal hides that initiate a
transformation in any animal they desire
but the most common animal forms are
those of a wolf coyote Fox don't get
that much so you're saying it's a living
person that's doing this why okay they
have the internet at this point can't
they like watch some Netflix why are
they out skinned walking skinwalker most
often kills out of greed anger and V
spite or revenge
so skinwalkers kill people but it's a
person killing people let's see um
navajo when it comes down to punishing
the skinwalker if it is caught in the
act
rarity indeed Navajo law is very direct
and straightforward when it comes to
witchcraft when a person becomes a witch
they immediately forfeit their humanity
and their right to exist in thus the
skinwalker can be killed any legal or
moral it's like Salem witch trials
they're like we're just you're not even
a person we're gonna kill you that's he
regards the magical practices
skinwalkers are said to gather in small
groups in dark caves in order to
initiate new members plot their
activities kill people from a distance
with black magic engage in necrophilia
with the female corpses wine to commit
cannibalism incest and grave robbery oh
my god that's just got really dark
I'm just I'm searching I'm searching the
word kill for this long article to see
if you can kill them or if they kill
people the skinwalkers described as
being extremely fast agile and
impossible to catch attempting the
shooter otherwise killers can walk are
usually unsuccessful and they may even
seek revenge that seems fair
the skinwalker is defend yourself or
protect yourself seems very yeah another
spell that the skinwalkers used to kill
is done by acquiring some of the victims
hair wrapping it around a pot pot shard
and then placing it into a tarantulas
hole live rattlesnakes may be released
into the victim's dwelling or his bed
oh no no no defeating a skinwalker
requires the assistance of a powerful
shaman in those spells and rituals any
shamans in the comments wanna like
protect us just in case we got any
shamans I'll take a pound apparently if
you have bullets and you dip them in
white ash which I don't even know what
whiteout what's why - I don't know what
just like I've learned to get way - what
hah what's why - this is a this is a
collaborative podcast guys what why - oh
ok species of tree native to eastern and
central North America Australia Texas
southern Oklahoma ok so it's it comes
from species of tree fraxinus Americana
the white ash or American ash is a
species of ash tree - native tree native
to eastern and central North America ok
so it's like it's from an ash tree so
before you grab your piece just dip the
magazine and bullets in some white ash
yeah then you're good to go
pretty much definitely for sure
goddamn dude well if you guys have any
skinwalker stories that you'd like to
share with us we'd be more than happy to
read them in the comments peachie are
you Pacific I was calling PG your car
man was like he G and then hurt someone
from the forest go like really I would
yell out in the woods ago [ __ ] you
skinwalker and then I would leave just
don't look him in the eye I won't I'll
blindfold myself echo you rode and you
got a bad attitude why don't you go
watch some Netflix like the rest of us
this is funny what he's post on the
skinwalkers it's like top post of all
it's the second top post a G PI is
secretly a skinwalker that's trying to
end net neutrality so less people can
have access to this subreddit yeah I
suggest checking this stuff out if you
guys want a good little spook I feel
like the first couple stories were a
little weird and more real but then when
we got to skinwalker things things
picked up pretty fast I'm terrified of
them just like your dog will pick up it
their appetite really fast once you
start feeding them the farmers dog oh
well thank you guys for listening I'm
just still confused that they're like
they're living people that are using
powers but like why like why would a
skinwalker go torment those two little
boys in the middle of nowhere or like
why would a skinwalker imitate that lady
with MSS dog like you mean like it's a
person it makes sense to me if they're
like operating within like their tribe
and they don't want to seek revenge
against another tribe or something like
that makes sense to me but like just
tormenting people for no reason doesn't
make any sense to me yeah that it made
more sense when they were like a
nonliving thing you know what I mean
yeah they're just like an entity but the
idea that it's a person behind there is
like what are you doing stop it
get some help stop it get some help
it's always like people get the weird
feeling that they're being like chased
or followed and then it turns out that
they turn around and see a skinwalker
yeah I know I'm most that that's
terrifying
yeah no thanks
so we have what we have two more
episodes of October podcasts let's see
do we have two more that's just scary
style yeah so we want you guys as advice
this one's going out 15th yep
so we have the 22nd and the 29th of
scary podcast opportunities so give us
ideas if you have any of what to record
for spooky podcasts and let me know like
how we can best prepare them I have my
pick what if this one's a skinwalker and
it isn't like you know they're my
protection
hmm well thank you guys for hanging out
hopefully you you were entertained by
this I'm scared
hopefully you were scared by this and
we'll see you guys next week for more
spooky stuff see you guys on Twitch in
the meantime and remember to send in
those suggestions well we're gonna start
really sweeping within that section
super sweet hanging so just in general
suggestions in the comments will be read
like a lot of them so give us
suggestions I'll see you guys later
[Music]
[Music]